- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to discuss income inequality,
which is something that is often debated,
thinking about comparing countries,
thinking about whether
it's an issue or not
and how to address it.
And to appreciate what
income inequality is,
let's imagine two different countries.
Let's imagine first, country A,
and there's two people in country A.
So, you have person one here,
who makes $1000 a year,
that's their income,
and then there's person two in country A
that makes $99,000 a year.
So, what is going to be the average income
in country A, if these
are the only two people?
Or you could think of it as
the per capita national income.
Well the average income here,
average income, to figure that out,
you would just have to average
the 1000 and the 99,000.
So you have a total income
of one plus 99, 100,000
divided by two folks,
well you're gonna have an average income
of $50,000 per year.
Now, let me construct another country
that has the same average income,
but the distribution is very different.
So in country B, let's say the
first citizen of country B,
they make $50,000 a year,
and let's say there's a
second person in country B,
and they also make $50,000 per year,
per year.
Well, what's the average income now?
Well, this is even easier
to compute, 50 plus 50
divided by two, your average
income is $50,000 per year.
So, what you see here is two countries
that if you just looked
at the average income,
they seem similarly wealthy,
but that doesn't give you,
they seem to have similar average incomes.
So you would say, oh maybe
they're similarly prosperous.
But when you go a step deeper,
you see that they are very different.
Country A is a lot more
unequal than country B,
when it comes to income.
So, question is, is above
and beyond looking at things
like average income or
average GDP or per capita GDP,
how do you measure inequality?
And this is something that
this Italian statistician,
Corrado Gini, tried to address,
and he comes up with something
called a Gini coefficient
to measure income inequality for a nation.
And the way he approached it
is actually pretty intuitive.
What he did is he sets up two axes.
So, this axis right
over here is going to be
the cumulative percentage
of the population.
So, you start at 0% and then
you get all the way to 100%
of the population.
So this is the cumulative
percent of the population
in a country, and then on
this axis, on this axis,
you have the cumulative percentage
of the income in a country.
So, this would be zero down here
and then this would be 100 up there.
And so, this is cumulative percent
of income in a country,
and then he said,
well what would a perfectly
equal society look like?
Well in a perfectly equal society,
as you add a percentage
on your cumulative
percentage of population,
you should add that exact same percentage
to your cumulative percentage of income.
So as you go up, you really
should just have a slope of one
going up like this.
So, one way to think about it is,
when you're at 0% of the population,
you should have 0% of the income.
If you have a total of
10% of the population,
they should have 10%
of the national income.
If you were to go to
50% of the population,
which looks like it's around there,
if it was perfectly
distributed, the income,
well then that should be
50% of the national income.
But no nation is actually there,
and so then we have to then
compare that to the reality.
So, let's say you look at a country,
and what you do is,
when you're looking at
the cumulative percentage
of the population, you start at the left
with the lowest income,
and as you add percentages
of the population, you get to higher
and higher income folks.
So, let's say we're looking at a country
that for the poorest folks,
as you add percentages to
the cumulative population,
you're not adding the same
percent to the cumulative income.
And so, you might have a
curve that looks like this,
and then as you add percentages
in the wealthier population,
for every 1% you add, you're adding
more than 1% of national income.
And so, this curve right over here,
which you could view as
describing the reality
for a certain nation,
this is known as a Lorenz curve,
Lorenz curve, and what Gini said is,
well the difference
between the Lorenz curve
and this line right over here,
that that would be a measure
of income inequality.
And so, he would look at this area
right over here, and say,
what percentage is this area
between this line and the Lorenz curve,
what percentage is this of
this total area under the line?
And this percentage is
called the Gini coefficient,
and it's typically quoted as being a value
from zero to one,
or sometimes you might
see the scale as being
from zero to 100.
So, what would a Gini
coefficient of zero represent?
Well, if you have a Gini
coefficient of zero,
that means that this area right over here
between the Lorenz curve
and this line is zero.
So that means that we are dealing
with a perfectly equal
income distribution.
So at the zero end, this
is perfect equality,
perfect income equality,
and then what does one or 100 mean?
That means that the area between the line
and the Lorenz curve is 100%
of the area under this line.
So that would look like
something like this,
a country whose Lorenz curve
looks like something like this,
where all of these people,
I keep adding more and
more and more population,
but I'm not adding more and more income,
and then all of a sudden, you
get to the very last person,
and then that person
has all of the income.
So, that person has all of the income.
Well in that case,
the Gini coefficient would be
the percentage of this area,
which would be 100%,
which we could view as a one or 100.
And so, an interesting thing to do is,
is look at Gini coefficients
for various countries
and compare them.
And that's exactly what
we have here on this map,
and you can see that the
countries that are shaded red,
these are countries that
have high Gini coefficients.
So, this is where you have
more income inequality,
and the ones that are
shaded green are the ones
where you have relatively low Gini indices
or Gini coefficients, and
so that would be indicative
of reasonably low income inequality.
Now, it's important to point out,
you might think that red is always bad
and green is always good,
but this just tells you inequality,
it does not tell you on average
how prosperous folks are,
what average income is in that country,
and so, this is an indication
that in places like Latin
America and Sub-Saharan Africa,
you definitely have very high inequality,
and places like Canada and Europe,
you seem to have very low inequality,
but it doesn't tell you that people
for sure are better off in Canada
than say the United States.
For example, you could have
a higher average income
in the United States
than you have in Canada,
and one can have a very spirited debate,
which one you would rather be.
Would you rather be in a country
that has higher inequality
and higher average income
or one that has lower
income and lower inequality?